amazing that an artist can have that
much power that much clout that she can
say I'm just gonna pull my music their
music for Spotify you and I don't turn
it down we can pull our duet which we
haven't recorded yet from Spotify any
time that we want we can do it our music
doesn't have to be there we don't have
to good permission other people have
done it as well it just hasn't gotten
this kind of attention or potentially
had this much impact well you know what
is the advantage so let's back up for a
second why does a musician want to be on
Spotify in the first place because
they're really not getting money on it
they're not gonna make any money the
royalty the the the money they see is
point zero zero zero zero six of a cent
I might have left a zero off there why
be on Spotify because we passed the
tipping point we're moving from an
ownership economy to a streaming economy
that's clear digital sales are down for
the first time in the iTunes era down
double digits for the last year we have
seen declining album sales in the
digital world and track sales but
subscriptions to digital services up
some 57% so we've reached the tipping
point that's the future that's where
we're headed and if you want to be in
the game you're gonna be on a stream
yeah here you got an artist like Taylor
Swift who who's been so successful in
terms of just actually selling her music
outright that she doesn't need the
streaming thing she doesn't and to be
perfectly clear Taylor has never had her
new albums on Spotify when she puts out
a new record when she put out read two
years ago it was absent from Spotify for
six months to a year she doesn't have
her new music there because she clearly
believes as some people do that
streaming cannibalizes sales but Taylor
is an exception she's gonna sell over
1.3 million albums in a week she's going
to be the first artist in history to
have three different records so more
than a million
one week the very first one there are
another artists like her she does some
pretty incredible things to drive sales
I mean social media for example stalking
Taylor hashtag well they did Taylor
lurking Taylor Stockman would be creepy
but Taylor lurking is nice that's the
hashtag that's the one that she's using
on Twitter to say to her fans I see you
I'm gonna retweet your pictures of you
buying my record and this is an artist
who grew up with social media myspace
was crucial to her when she first
started at 15 years old she put up
videos of herself on there she would
film herself doing everything edit the
videos herself on her on her own Mac and
then put them up and she's still doing
the same thing she's just using
different kinds of ways of communicating
with her fans I'm Carrie she's an
incredibly talented artist
and that in and of itself being a
singer-songwriter is is a gift
how is she is a businessperson I mean is
this actually hers there's a team around
her her team this is her team everyone
says there's not a decision that comes
out of the Taylor Swift world that
doesn't go through Taylor and almost all
of them come from Taylor to find an
artist who's disengaged as a songwriter
and the successful as a songwriter is
extraordinarily rare to find someone
who's disengaged as a businessperson is
extraordinarily rare and to find that
same person who does both things it's
pretty good I would say um so what
what's the key though for your average
musician trying to make it in this
environment right now you know with the
Spotify so making any money exactly what
you can take away from this from if
there's a lesson the average musician
can learn it's one they probably already
know which is be connected to your fans
be connected to your fans yourself don't
hire other people to connect you to your
fans take control of the process and do
it yourself when Taylor Swift writes in
The Wall Street Journal I don't think
music should be free I think music is
valuable people should pay for it you
know what what can the average musician
do maybe not sell albums but sell
tickets t-shirts on tour live music is
key to people being healthy in the music
industry that's kind of always been the
way it has been
right in the music industry mean you
didn't make much on album sales you made
money on tour that's right and you know
when artists get up in arms about not
making money on Spotify
they really are continuing a tradition
of being upset not being paid much by
the music industry at all most artists
even if they sold a lot of Records made
the majority of their earnings live on
tour okay so she's going on tour she
announced a world tour today any idea
how much Taylor Swift is gonna make on
tour well I don't know I will say that
we estimated that in 2013 she earned
about forty million dollars through
touring album sales and some
merchandising we didn't have an estimate
for all of her merchandising that is a
lot of money for anyone she was our
number-one earner in 2013 in billboards
money list